well it's very simple Central Bank
digital currencies are programmable so
it essentially means that it's a much
more easier way to push agendas
political agendas for example the world
economic forum is talking about
implementing a a carbon allowance so
every individual will be given a certain
amount of carbon that they are allowed
to emit into the atmosphere with a
central bank digital currency this
becomes far more efficient because with
a click of a button you literally just
program the money and so if for whatever
reason you buy too many burgers too many
sausages one week when you go to fill up
your car your money could be canceled it
could get declined simply because you
you use too much of your carbon
allowance essentially or even if you go
to buy a plane ticket it could get
canceled because you bought too many
burgers you bought too much meat that
week so it's much easier to push forward
political agendas and political
ideologies when you have money which is
programmable with just a click of a
button
it's not really money is it a central
bank digital currency it's more of a an
outward demonstration of your uh your uh
obedience to whatever is the message of
the day and and you get rewarded with a
certain amount of purchasing power
exactly so in Canada for example during
the height of the pandemic if you didn't
want to get vaccinated and you just
wanted to
um protest bodily autonomy you would
have your money and your bank account
shut down and declined because you
weren't a good citizen so with a central
bank digital currency it doesn't matter
what your opinion is if you do not hold
the correct opinion if you're not a good
citizen then absolutely that money will
will be programmed to be used against
you even in the height of the pandemic
you had to be chaperoned to go into
certain stores so it creates a far more
efficient way to discriminate against
certain people you don't need that
middle man anymore again with a click of
a button if you're not a good citizen
your money will be programmed to be used
against you
well you notice I introduced you
specifically as a Bitcoin Enthusiast
among a dizzying collection of
cryptocurrencies and you and many others
insist Bitcoin and Bitcoin alone is safe
from State interference why are you able
to say that that is so
yeah that's absolutely correct so
Bitcoin is completely decentralized
there's no CEO there's no council
there's no one founder that can program
the money or do anything it's completely
decentralized so it's fully immune from
any form of government intervention
people get quite confused because
sometimes if you hold your Bitcoin on a
centralized exchange then of course the
government in that country can tell the
exchange to shut you down that's very um
that's very common and that can happen
it happened in Canada during the protest
but if you hold your Bitcoin in the
correct way which means you take
absolute custody of it so there's no
middleman then nobody can touch it it's
just you and the Bitcoin also it's
completely Anonymous so there's no kyc
there's no what they call know your
customer regulations whereby you know
you have to identify yourself with that
money it's completely Anonymous so
whatever your opinion is nobody has
access to your Bitcoin and nobody can um
shut it down